foreign
all right so uh being a little after 9
30 we'll open
the work session on House Bill 571
relative to the cost of living
adjustments for a certain group who
retirees in the New Hampshire Retirement
System
all right
any thoughts members of the division
give you a chance to get to your
into your binders um
did you get a binder representative
grassy with all the bills in it no
I think I do here
the clerk will go get some clients
yeah I think the last day we heard it
from my notes was uh
March 2nd
this Pirates
so
yeah go ahead represent Griffin
yeah I mean
I I don't understand why
this is only for one group
and uh
to the exclusion of I guess group one
well we have to find spotsy
we have the prime sponsor here
representative baroody would you like to
speak to representative Griffin's
question why it was just uh feel free to
take the mic yeah
make sure you put the mic on
there you go okay I'm Ben Rooney from
Manchester uh the group two people this
is just an attempt to catch up to people
in group one
um they haven't been getting coal is I
think they got two in the last 19 years
and uh they've been falling way behind
and this is just an attempt to catch up
to everybody else
further question uh follow up sure
one has been getting colas and group two
hasn't been yeah they have yeah
you would like to join representative
parody at the table please
and state your name for the record
he knows the nuts and bolts better than
I do
good evening committee members my name
is Arthur Beaudry I'm the president of
the New Hampshire State permanent
firefighters retirement Association
um yes group one uh over the over the
course of time has gotten considerably
more uh colas than group two and the big
thing is group two does not receive
Social Security so last year
um when you when they gave that stipend
out of the 11.6 million dollars uh 10.75
million of that went to group one
um the way that the way that uh
legislation change because of this
committee they they put it so that it
was less than thirty thousand dollars
the median for uh group two is right
around uh 38 to 40 000 so if that that
bill did not help group two at all and
over time I have I have the data that
teaches
um uh like 13 to 14 percent over uh
group two as far as cost of living
raises because back in in the 80s and
early 90s when their special account was
around it it had to do with what money
was available in the special account for
you to get a cola so if group two didn't
get have money in their special account
we received nothing but if group one had
money they received colas so in the in
the 80s and early 90s uh teachers uh
were getting five percent cost of living
raises when group two were getting zero
can you share that data with us I can I
can share it every time a system should
have it too but I I can look through it
and I can I can share what uh I have
which I did give to uh Marty but he's I
don't know if he printed it or not
the clerk has a question uh she didn't
get your first name Sir Mr Bogan
I have uh Kohler adjustments from July
88 to 2007.
um teachers received a 69.25 cost living
raise in that time frame where
firefighters receive 54.5 percent
did you make that information available
to the division I mean the notes on the
bottom of this page are my notes the
rest of it is from the retirement system
but my notes is from the two colas that
were granted
um in 2010 and 2019 they're both one and
a half percent coolest but I can if they
want to make copies of this yeah Mr
Hoffman please
thanks
thank you but the the major factor is
social security that we don't receive so
uh group one got eight point seven
percent so security this year police and
fire didn't receive that because we
don't get Social Security
represent McGuire has a question thank
you Mr chairman
um so in general the reason teachers got
a bigger part is the last Cola was
limited to those with thirty thousand
dollar pension or less whereas police
and fire are averaging closer to 40
right teachers and everybody else are
averaging more like 20. so that's that
that's why the reason that's why it was
skewed
um all right so here's my suggestion for
this bill
um
this the reason it's so expensive the 84
million is because this is allocating
money permanently to this to this group
right it's it's it's really a pretty
honest bill in the sense that
um it creates this this supplement uh
forever and and fully pays for it this
year okay
um in the in the past when we've done
colas it's been for the
um like well the like the cola we did in
the last budget was just a one-time
payment it wasn't a forever kind of a
payment so
um I think that's what we need to do
with this one is say okay we'll take
care of you
for this budget season but let let
people decide in next budget season and
after and after what they're going to do
so
um
I think Marty's not here and I don't
have the detailed numbers but I think if
this became a one-time payment it would
be something other you know with the
same formula I think it would be
something under 10 million dollars you
know maybe close to 10 8 to 10 or
something like that be my guess but I I
don't know it for sure
Melissa could we reach out to the
Retirement Board and see if we can get a
firm number on representative McGuire's
suggestion yes we can and um Marty just
emailed me saying he wasn't able to
attend this morning but he did send over
accounts for who's receiving this so if
you want to back into a payment you want
to say they got a one-time one thousand
dollar payment or we could back into it
now that we have the numbers but I also
can reach out for that that would be
perfect do you recall what the amount
was in dollar figures just for the last
Cola that
less than those people that get
something that receive less than 30.
sure so they received a 500 payment if
they're um
retirement allowance was
um less than 30 000 and the there was an
appropriation for
11.75 million
thank you representative Griffin
I wonder why we're dealing with the
Retirement Board and I guess this is
this is their information correct the
top part is the the notes on the bottom
of mine but I understand
it'd be interesting to know
which of those increases were one year
and which were permanent I can tell you
all of them were permanent that's all
permanent coal is right there
when we had the special account
everything was um
was permanent there was no one-time I
shouldn't say there was one some
one-time uh
stipends but thought that data is all
permanent coales that went into your
base
if you could confirm that Melissa with
the retirement
represent Maguire all right so notice
that this chart sort of ends on
2007 right 2008 and the the so the the
whole reason we have a 5.7 billion
dollar debt is because of the special
account right because there were there
were times when the
um retirement
um return on investments was higher than
the expected return our current expected
return is 6.75 percent so there were
times when the return was nine percent
ten percent like that right and and they
put some of that extra into the special
account and gave it away in extra
benefits right and and so but the
problem is the 6.75 percent is an
average it's it's not a maximum and so
there's going to be years when it's
negative like last year they had a minus
six percent return right so
so that's how they got in trouble and
and so they they gave away like this
list shows they gave away extra benefits
that were not part of the you know well
anyway they gave away extra benefits and
so got into trouble and and so not only
are we paying for that trouble now we're
asking for even more extra benefits now
so you know
it's it's a hard thing to to fund I
think can I make sure what the committee
commitment why I said is somewhat
accurate but back back when the special
account was set up the uh interest
assumption rate was nine percent and
anything over nine and a half percent
would go into the special account and
that really wasn't the reason why that
was some of the reason why we ran into
problems but the main reason why we
rented the problems is when they uh got
the Social Security offset for group one
back in 1988 it was a 200 million dollar
piece of legislation that wasn't fully
funded and if you look back in history
and you look at the employer
contribution rates after 88 the next
evaluation that was was set up the group
one rates doubled because of the Social
Security offset that's when they went
decided well we're going to change the
methodology to open group aggregate
which was going to push the liabilities
out further and we've really never paid
the liabilities off and then they
changed the entrance assumption rate to
nine and three quarters percent which
saved the cities and towns 72 million
dollars and the reason why I know these
numbers I was on the Retirement Board
when all that stuff happened
um so that that was the main driver of
uh the system
um not being fully funded plus the the
actuary in my opinion was wrong by
saying we were 135 percent funded back
then and they wrote down 20 percent of
the assets to pay for the Social
Security offset
well the situation where of course now
is as a result as representative McGuire
stated some of the past practices and
now we're just trying to play catch-up
or at least try to restore some uh a
little credibility to the process and
take care of the unfunded liability
issue which I think we've done
some great stuff with as far as putting
some of that money aside for the
unfunded liability in one of the house
bills and I agree but as I testified on
this bill earlier we over 637 million
dollars was in the special account over
from 2009 to 2012. that money was all
captured and put into the Corpus and
what it did is low of contribution rates
to the cities and towns on the backs of
the retirees because that was money that
should have been used to fund colas and
they took it off us the legislature
wrote legislation to take that money
capture it and put it in the Corpus of
the fund which load employer cost on the
backs of the retirees so I did I know
there's going to be a balance no
disagreement there but I'm just saying
the situation we're in now we're trying
to wrestle with balancing the budget and
trying to be fair to all retirees and
the people that are participating in the
system and just speaking for myself I
just think representative McGuire's
suggestion is probably a good one I
don't think we afford the 84 million but
we could probably afford a one-time cost
of living
increase as representative McGuire has
suggested but I'd like to hear from
other members of the division first
representative kimberles yes thank you
Mr chair I also agree with that
opposition and I think I think it's fair
it's what we can afford to do and uh as
representative McGuire stated we as a
legislature should not be making a
policy I think that that's going to run
out forever allow the future legislate
legislators to you know take it session
by session in regards to
you know remedy given them the ultimate
remedy or over the course of many years
so
thank you representative Hewitt any
thoughts there or
Mike
I'm interested in we're talking about
making a one-time caller now I'm
wondering whether any of the ecolas that
we're talking about for example on this
form uh were one-time colas uh my
understanding is that when cost of
living increases were given they were
continuous
and you know to now say we're going to
give the uh we're going to give the
firefighters a one-time
what's going to happen the next time
well that will be up to the next
legislature right and that's been the
problem all along
representative evil any thoughts
I mean I guess I would like to see what
the cost is for the one-time Cola and
then compare it to what would be
appropriated under this bill
and we will have that I assume today
Melissa you think from Marty I just sent
him the email so hopefully we'll get it
today as soon as I know I'll let you
know all right representative McGuire
yeah so just to here's my back of the
envelope calculation if you give the the
pension fund 84 million dollars they'll
think of it that they can generate 84
million times 6.75 percent forever
right so 84 million times seven percent
is roughly 55 5.5 million or something
like that right well they'll also think
that these are people who are retired 10
plus years so they're going to be uh um
dying off at some point so therefore we
could spend a little more now right so a
little more is going to get you into the
maybe eight to ten million dollar a year
range to start with and then it would
Fade Out over time
um may I ask I want to ask these guys a
question if I might sure yeah absolutely
so
to me this
um this payment is a is a kind of a
charity right it's it's
um
it's not something we're obligated to do
it's something we want to do to help out
this group of people okay
but the way it's written the people who
are currently getting the best pension
get more than the people getting the
least pension right which is sort of the
opposite of the way you do charity right
with with Charity you you help the
people who are worse off more and at
least off less so I'm wondering if and
the other thing this this particular
bill has is it has kind of a step right
it's it's you know if you've been
retired nine and a half years nothing if
you've been retired 10 and a half years
up there and the same thing at the 20
year mark right you know if you're if
you've been retired 19 and a half years
you get half as much as the guy retired
20 plus years right so but it'd be cold
if I may every cola that's ever been
granted
has that provision you have to have a
start point and unfortunately it's all
you know it's usually been July 1st so
if I get on the job June 30th I don't
get it you know so it right but that so
let me let me continue the thought so
first of all we could do it more like a
fixed payment to everybody everybody
gets two thousand dollars three thousand
dollars whatever the number is
um and therefore
um
therefore it helps the the person with
the smallest pension as much as the
person with the highest pension right we
could also make it capped in some sense
so if your pension is already
a hundred thousand dollars or something
you don't get you don't get the two
thousand or three thousand whatever you
see what I mean so would something like
that be
um
what is your thoughts about it's
changing the structure I guess it's a
lot more complicated than what you think
because I'll give you a scenario if I if
I was a firefighter that had 30 years on
the job I retired I took my spouse for a
hundred percent of my my pension when uh
and I take a reduction the cover of my
spouse for that 100 I pass away now
she's collecting 100 of my pension
because I took a reduction
firefighter B might have worked 20 years
only took a 50 percent
um pension for his spouse that person
dies she's getting 50 so she's going to
get she's going to get more money than
the person that worked the 30 years
because her husband chose only cover her
for 50 instead of 100 that the other
firefighter covered her for so it it it
when you look at the totality it people
are giving up money to cover their
spouses for a benefit and that's where
it gets complicated that there's some
members that take a straight pension
don't cover their spouse for anything
um so they're going to get a higher cost
of living raise because they chose to
take a straight annuity and and not not
give up any money to cover their spouse
or other members did so that's where the
fairness is and I think over the years
it's always been when you give a caller
it's it's based on actually we just
started this probably
five years ago in 2019 was the first
time we started going on a certain
amount it was always based on the
person's complete pension and then they
decided well we're going to go with 30
000 in in two 2019 they booted that up
to uh 50 000 I think because of the
testimony from group two because we
don't get Social Security we should get
a little bit more so they booted it up
to 50 000 and then last year it was at
fifty thousand but this committee chose
to give it to people that make less than
thirty thousand which pretty much
excluded group two so I don't know if I
answered your question but it it is a
little more difficult than all right let
me let me follow up slightly so
um you said person X is getting more
than person Y what I suggested was
everybody get the same so you know but
but it's really more
um I guess Police Chief versus you know
Beat cop or something or standard
officer right police chief has got twice
the pen
so the police chief that may be making
more than 50 is only going to get it on
the first fifty thousand right okay
um or maybe person who retired in 1980
versus person who retired in uh 2000
right their their salary in general in
2000 was much higher than their salaries
in in 1980 right so
so the whole point is
it to me it just seems fairer to to
spread it out more evenly rather than as
a percentage because as a percentage
already the ones making fifty thousand
dollar pensions are getting twice as
much as those making twenty five
thousand dollar pensions right I know
you may not like this answer but what
you could do is base your base it on a
fifty thousand dollar pension so if it's
you know uh five percent of fifty
thousand twenty five hundred dollars
everybody gets twenty five hundred bucks
you can go that route too
so that's my question is that's my
question would that be objectionable to
to you well I think it's been so long
that we've we've haven't had a cola that
I applaud anybody on this committee to
work to try to get the firefighters
something
um so and uh the frustrating part is I
think we still have to go back at some
point the legislature is going to have
to realize that there's going to be a
mechanism for ongoing colas that coming
back every year like last year when we
came back it wasn't a budget year you
said don't we can't do anything for you
come back this year because it's a
budget year so we came back this year
and this it's the same answer we don't
have the money so come back another year
and so at some point they got to
recognize that colas were always part of
the retirement system from the Inception
of 1963. hi 67. the grant Coles were
always granted and now all of a sudden
they kind of forgot the retirees and
we haven't had colas in like I said one
Kohler and since 2010.
well we could that's another discussion
I think all right I'd like to hear from
representative baruti if he has any
thoughts on this aspect like like uh Mr
Bowden said I think that
for this year if we're not going to be
able to get what we asked for a one-time
shot is better than nothing I think the
guys would be happy to get anything
because up until now we've got nothing
so I mean the attempt is good you know I
applaud you for that but at some point
I'd like to see them catch up
I don't know if we can change the rate
or whatever representative grassy has
more money to invest represent grassy as
a question or a statement I yeah I don't
have a question I just wanted to
basically agree with representative
McGuire this is something that you know
when we were doing colas as a city
council member we would do colas which I
think as representative Hewitt has said
usually increases their base pay you
know increases the pay of everyone but
there are many times that we were unable
to do that and I think that the fairest
way we did is we took how much money did
we have
we figured out what that would be for a
percentage across averaged out across
the board and then if it was a thousand
dollars or if it was twenty five hundred
dollars everybody got that up to a cap
that's people over a certain amount
didn't didn't get it but you know most
everybody got it so the person at the
bottom the person who's struggling the
most got the most money and the person
at the top who needed it less got least
money got the least money but you know
that's what we did we took it at least
percentage they didn't get to lose money
but they got the least percentage so and
I think that's a if it's a reasonable a
reasonable idea and something we should
consider
thank you so I was going through my
retirement file here that and I see that
the there was a period from 20
2013 70 uh 17 no colas 11.
to 12 no colas
08 to 10 there was a fifth 1.5 Cola for
the first thirty thousand
and then prior to
um
2008 and I don't know where these colas
came from there's no note on the
retirement breakdown but there were
coal is small some you know as much as
4.5 for everybody going back to 1997. do
you know where those coal is provided by
the retirement system or the legislature
everything was legislatively we always
had to go to the legislative even when
the special account was was uh enacted
they still had to go to the legislature
for approval for the cost of living
raise
because I remember some talk that um way
back that a lot of the colas were coming
from the Corpus and not General funds
maybe the legislature just said okay but
it was coming from the Corpus versus a
general fund appropriation that's true
that's true I would say
until 2010 maybe all those colas were
coming out of um were coming out of the
retirement system and they were they
were basically billing the local
communities for the cost of the cola
okay
so yes Melissa I just want to say that
Marty confirmed that all of these colas
are permanent have been permanent colas
okay thanks
are there any further questions
on this
the McGuire proposal we'll call it it
seems to be some support for at least a
one-time payment which would be in the
neighborhood of about 12 million dollars
I believe for up to 30.
um
yeah
representative Griffin
I'd like to see uh right what polls have
been issued since
2007.
thank you
yeah it might be in your file but the
sheet that I handed out stops at the end
of that that sheet Carries On from the
sheet that I gave you
Mike do you have that uh could you get
this from representative is that oh yeah
that's the same one okay okay thanks
sure so 2007 2008 was was a kind of a
double whammy year because 2008 the
stock market dropped significantly and
it was also when
the unfunded liability sort of perked up
to the the attention of the of the
legislature and so
um since then I think there's been very
few because you know things we've been
trying to fix the you know the those
past problems that occurred during the
the period when these callers were were
given so yeah
and to add to that I think my memory
serves me right when this whole thing
became a problem
is that the legislature or maybe the
retirement system somebody wasn't paying
attention they were taking the colas out
of the Corpus and not realizing the
impact that would have long term so
there weren't general fund
Appropriations that was coming out of
the retirement system
and if I may Mr chairman that's that's
how it was set up even prior to the
special account I was up here from 1980
when the session used to be every other
year and they would set their budget and
give a two-year Cola and it would always
come out of the Corpus that would it
wasn't until just recently
um and that this bill is set up uh to
have it come out of the general fund but
um there's a bill that was stated
at the last hearing that's coming out of
the Senate that's coming out of the
corpus
you know we certainly don't want to make
the unfunded liability any worse than it
is so
I think the only place it could come out
of realistically would be General funds
might
that's so cheap
all right well I don't see any
further questions we'll wait for that
additional information from the
retirement system on the um
McGuire proposal for a one-time payment
yes represent evil what what was the
Social Security increase this year was
it 8.7 percent
highest it's been in about 50 years I
believe
if I may ask I know you threw some
numbers around but what are you going to
base your uh I'll call it a stipend one
the total
the total amount you mean to spend yes
yeah so I I was thinking 10 million
dollars 10 million and and depending on
how many firefighters and police
officers are in those two groups that
would just divide that up essentially
yes we might have a cap
you know so that if you're you're
current so the way I'm thinking about it
the the the the taxpayer the average
wage earner in in New Hampshire their
salary is 52 000 a year so
there's some in this group
their pensions are much higher than that
right and so that's some that's that's
really 95 of the pensioners make less
than fifty thousand dollars I understand
but there's some yeah but so that's why
we cap it at 50 so that yeah we we don't
give someone that's making a hundred
thousand dollars the the you know the
well the big pay raise the point is you
cap it you cap the base of the
calculation at 50 but you don't cap if
somebody was had a pension of a hundred
thousand dollars they would still get
the the x times 50 000. and so we could
have a cap in the sense of nobody's
nobody's total payment is more than a
hundred thousand dollars if you see what
I mean by adding this money
so you don't really have a dollar amount
you're just you're just gonna well we
could no no we can we'll get it we can
we can work it to make a dollar amount
okay that's what I mean you're gonna
you're coming out with a total dollar
amount a total dollar amount and then
figure it out and figure out what the
amount per person will be yeah exactly
okay yeah
yes representative grass yeah I think we
should we should figure out a percentage
and then we should figure out a wage
that we wanted like if it's fifty
thousand dollars and we want to give
everybody who makes fifty thousand
dollars a five percent raise
take whatever that comes out to
um then that's the amount of money that
we have in the pool and then we just
divide it equally amongst all the
employees so the guy at the bottom is
going to get probably eight or nine
percent raised whereas the guy at the
top could get a one or two percent raise
or stipend
yeah we'll look at a number of different
formulas right
representative evil well all I was going
to say is I think there's consensus that
we're going to do something yeah sure
okay I don't know if that's helpful but
that's better than right
it would appear you know from when I'm
listening to a year that will at least
make something for those
um making 50 000 or less in their
pension some kind of a percentage and
we'll try to work it so it's a little
heavier towards those that are making
say 25
000 versus 50. that's I think yeah
I agree I agree
it is
yes yeah I would being a math guy uh by
default if everybody gets an equal
payment the people are on a lower scale
are getting a higher percentage raise so
you know that's it's a no-brainer you
know
all right
okay well uh be in touch representative
parody and
or you can come tonight or this
afternoon you know
if we brought up again this afternoon
what's that you say no we're just having
a full Committee hearing on different
things this afternoon is the public
hearing for the budget so it starts at
two o'clock in reps Hall but I doubt you
would want to go
I don't want to go so therefore I like
getting a root canal yeah
remind me with
what these two major debt
the inflation rate so if you're trying
to figure out percentages colas and
it's about seven or eight percent
something like that I believe the Social
Security was the inflation rate wasn't
it 8.75
inflation rate yeah okay all right
yeah right all right thanks
all the colas were based on the cpiu so
it's Consumer Price Index Urban
cpiu but we don't we're not sure what
that was yes Consumer Price Index Urban
no no I mean the percentage okay
so wondering what the number was
so we'll wait and we'll get we'll make a
decision this week on this matter we
need to thank you very much yeah thanks
no
so uh Melissa Mr Hoffman you had a
handout
that you gave us a little update and I
think you have more updates for us as
well
it depends
it's 70.4 I printed mine out at home
this way so it's 70.4
foreign
yeah oh yeah it should be
it will be noted as far as when we exec
it
yeah we should talk about that yeah
I mean we have so many
yeah you do I think so
why is so here's the uh this will be
very helpful that you're getting right
now it will show everything that we've
done is grayed out in those areas it's
still under consideration or in white
and Mr Hoffman will
speak to this as soon as everyone's got
a copy so why is House Bill 250 not on
this let's do we already decide on it is
that
I think he was wrong let's see it was
indeterminable
250 what do we do here
Italian just a second
yeah so two 250 is still on our list to
discuss
right
we had a work session on the 3rd of
March and
it was still open
I'm not sure why it's not on that list
though yeah because I don't think its
status is really any different than 571
well it was indeterminable the amount of
money so maybe that's why it's not about
oh I see
yeah so this is the death benefit of
someone's I feel in the line of duty I
think it's because the impact occurs
outside of the budget so the impact
occurs in uh fiscal year 2026 the
indeterminable cost for 24 and 25 are
related to the pension uh the system
changes so they wouldn't be very much
money
have we ever asked the the sponsors
whether they intended to benefit the 19
individuals who are currently in that
situation the 19 spouses I think they
said yes wasn't that
they say it was going to include
everyone to a hundred percent off the
top of my set head it was retro it was
for new from that point forward we do
have an email out to them asking the
cost if we made it retroactive I see
yeah because I think the sponsor's
intent was retroactive but I don't know
I'm not sure I don't remember I think
that's what they said
100 from the 50 that it is now yeah so
there therefore it's not a zero it's not
a zero but hopefully it never happens
except for those that are already
getting the 50 benefit but
um
could we find the book for
representative uh from Rochester the
bill book that bill hatched it must be
I'll go get it
yeah
because it'd be helpful if he had all
the information that we're working with
so for those of you that can't read the
number on the sheet that Mr Hoffman gave
out earlier it's 70.4 in that black box
on
that's this sheet here the single sheet
that we got a little earlier
with the uh it's
you know there's a number in the Box 70
0.4
so that's our magic number that we have
to tready knocked down a little bit
represent Maguire thank you so is this
paper showing that we're actually in in
Balance sort of because we have a minus
70.4 here but we have pluses
oh no it's the 37 is the only real plus
right at the end
right so we're we're still like 35 under
sort of
for 33 or something
oh okay
yeah that would be great Mike yeah no I
meant the the overall budget right so
I believe the two key numbers are the
70.4 2023 number and the 37.4 the the
2025 number right and one is negative
and the other is positive so thinking of
the budget as a whole
um
right now we would be effectively taking
out 33 million from the rainy day fund
if everything on this paper happened you
see what I mean
aren't both 2024 and 2025 positive
numbers
well 2024 is an intermediate number if
you look at that 43.7 yeah
I believe it goes back to the top of the
page yes
where is it it should go to the top 2023
is the only negative number the and the
other two are positive numbers and look
to your point they kind of wash well
that see that's a little it's confusing
because actually everything in
parentheses that's a plus like if you
look at it's a plus for us well it's a
if you it's a minus for us it in other
words generally I know it's a little
confusing but that so go to something
easy to look at go to House Bill 571
they call it see it shows a negative
because it's in parentheses but it's
actually it's a positive it's impacting
the budget or the unfunded liability
that's highlighted at 50.
so you would think oh that's we're
taking away but that's an ad all those
things in parentheses are ads the
numbers that are
without parentheses or take away
from the number
you know why we always yeah it's like
backwards it's not intuitive
you did
Maguire
suggested yeah with 10 million instead
of the 84. yeah it would be a 10 in
there then we're done yeah we're done
almost except you know okay we want to
make changes so yeah well let's see
I'll just try to give a little bit of
context and hopefully it helps it
is
I believe not positives so you're
starting up top with where the
governor's ending balances which is a
positive
94 million and 23 24 is a positive 25 is
a positive
the next line you come down that's the
difference just for general fund and
what house Ways and Means
revenues came out versus the governor so
in fiscal year 23 it was 5.4 million
less
than the governor's budget
so you're taking that out the next lines
are all the changes to the bills that we
currently have acted on same with
division two and three and then
um
you're going to get down there's some
other adjustments and Appropriations
that Mike Kane has noted I don't know
what they are exactly for but it's for
physical statutory miscellaneous
then you have a subtotal of the House
Appropriations which is 159 million
dollars
the variance is 164. I think that's the
159 plus the 5.4 leaving the balance in
23 is a negative 70.4 if you stop today
and just acted today that would be a hit
against the rainy day fund in fiscal
year 23. so you decrease the rainy day
fund at this point today by 70.4 million
dollars
they are negative and then you go up to
24 and 25 now here's your new budget
same sort of exercise except at the end
you can see we're ending 24
43.7 and that's actually
going to 25 that's 2.8 million less than
what the governor had to spend so you're
really even though it's a positive
number at the end it's still less than
the governor so you actually are short
from the governor's budget 2.8 million
okay that's up on the line that says
prior your carry forward versus governor
up if you see that up at the top in 25
so it takes that out so you're ending 25
in a positive at 37.4 if that's helpful
oh yeah it is it it's a little different
than like standard accounting yes yes I
know you got to go back and forth the
positives and the negatives so it's
legislative accounting so one one other
big error on this I think is look at
House Bill 436 we lost the 25 million
that
was in 2024 and I don't think that
decision has been made that was just
that was just an error in the fiscal
note the first time the 25 million is
appropriated is in 25. it's in 25 and
then in 26 the appropriation starts in
25 so it's just a revision to reflect
what is actually on the bill
S
I was just reading your email that you
sent this morning to me yeah sorry I
know it's confusing um
sorry so for the record my K and the LBA
Mike will set it all astray because
you'll see it oh perfect it's
legislative accounting here it is and so
really what I try to highlight and it
doesn't really show up so great on the
um when I have it in dark but basically
based on the spending through last
Friday and the decisions on the
divisions uh which just a majority
happening in one and two uh there would
have to be a drawer of 70 million
dollars and 23 out of the rainy day fund
so that 159.9 balance would come down to
about 89.9
so that's how the year would end the
year that's 23 that's going to end on
June 30th 23. based on your decisions
for 24 and 25 the budget that you're
developing now in houseboat one and two
uh you are in a positive position at the
end of the biennium so 25 I heard
representative McGuire mentioning that's
the important year to keep an eye on uh
based on all your decisions you'd end
with a positive balance of 37.4 so apps
in any other decisions
um then 37.4 would go into the rainy day
fund
so basically you're 89.9 just add
another 37 million to that to bring her
up to about
130 or so
but it would require
now if everything passed as is before he
went obviously I was just listening to
your debate on the cola bill for group
two I'm sure that will change I'm sure
you're going to talk about some of the
large Appropriations in 23 that may
change the other divisions are also
talking about some of their
Appropriations so it's just kind of a
quick snapshot of what would occur
and we're not required to spend
everything
all right
well that's that's your model yeah
but but I personally I don't like the
fact that 436 changed
by 25 it looked like it's 25 million
easier because really that bill is a 250
million dollar bill it's just that it
shifted by one more year so it's 25
million this budget but 50 50 50 50 25
like that right that's correct and so
yeah until
that's correct so in some sense
this is less honest than the 571 because
571 said we want this and you and right
now right
um whereas this one they want this but
right now it's only that you know what I
mean so yeah
representative evil I see a reaching for
you well I I don't want to sound like a
broken record but let's not forget that
if we don't repeal the communications
tax we've got another
30-ish per
year is that right well I think Mike
you've been including that in this
numbers right that it's been repealed
right that's correct if you um reverse
the repeal you pick up I think it's
about 28.9 a year yes so it's about 29 a
year yeah
yes so what we're seeing in front of us
I think what Mr Kane has said these
numbers include the repeal but if yeah
okay
I we have an idea along those lines but
it's it's still percolating so I'm not
quite ready
to propose it right now but yeah I we're
well aware about that with the
communication text
I was and I've been telling Mike Melissa
division one got a lot of bills you got
a lot of house filled to Appropriations
you have the highest number of agencies
that you're going through you're doing a
great job uh kind of cutting those off
but there's a lot of dollars in division
one but you know you're going through it
I know division three you know they have
over half the budget
tough decisions they have to make and
you can look on this page they have some
bills but they're also having some
pretty significant debate on where they
want that to go
keep in mind and again you can only
focus on your division we're going to
track all the other divisions as they
make their decisions uh division three
you know may need additional money but
we'll just continue to update uh the
committee as we go forward but right now
um you know other than 23 with some big
decisions kind of remaining out there
you're in a good position for 24.25
we have excellent help from your office
it keeps us on track yes you get two of
them so the extra bonus
so we need extra help
represent Maguire so I don't see any
House Bill 2 changes in either of the
other two divisions are they
like further behind than we are
um not behind
um
oh great I wouldn't say the brand like
division two does have one houseboat 560
that they're going to move into house
bill to
um on the education trust fund side
which is separate from this sheet
because division two is going to focus
on the education trust fund they did
remove 75 million dollars in building
Aid uh so the education trust fund uh
that they're looking at right now has a
balance of about 104 million dollars but
I know there are going to be debates in
division two relative to education
funding uh School building in a couple
other requests from the other agencies
uh division three hasn't made any
decisions relative to House Bill 2 yet
their largest is I think it's about a 35
million dollar appropriation for rate
increases that they're going to talk
about later this week on how they want
to
um uh kind of divvy those out I think
you remember the governor presenting a
3.1 percent Medicaid rate increase
across the board division threes uh
having discussions now and if there
should be providers that should receive
different amounts
but as I've heard right now they've kind
of staying within that amount I mean
obviously that could change
um and I think division two their
biggest decisions left to make on House
Bill to or education funding uh building
Aid or their two largest dollar ones
all right are there any questions for Mr
Kane
Mike and his staff are amazing so I
think you guys have already figured that
out so
thanks Mike thank you we'll continue to
update everyone I'll send this update at
the end of each day once I talk to Mike
Melissa and the other analysts based on
decisions or even ideas that divisions
are considering I can send you a regular
update on kind of where you'll end up
through the entire division entire
committee so you have an idea of kind of
where you're heading
represent Maguire so we approved two
extra Auditors in um
the dra and they they claimed that by
doing so we would gain like two and a
half million in 2025 is this shown in
this paper somewhere uh not yet we just
want to get the splits from uh dra I
think you approved two multi-state
Auditors could have an impact up to two
and a half to three million dollars and
twenty five uh that would be it's not
reflected yet that would be additional
we just wanted to make sure that we had
sometimes tra when they get new waterers
May focus on a specific tax a type of
tax so once we get their estimates on
which fund be it general education trust
fund we can update the sheet but
Melissa's already reached out to them
any further questions for Mr Kane again
thanks Mike
sure and feel free to um Mike and
Melissa we text regularly they're not
talking to their uh friends on there
yeah yeah and I'm watching as I can
between the other divisions but I'm
willing to come over anytime if you have
any questions so okay
well I was
I would say on
the fast Bill 212 we're still
anticipating getting something from Des
that would actually
change the text of what the fun can be
used for and add the 2 million we would
lose this two million dollars if that's
done it would just yeah we gotta get
down
yeah it would knock it down I I still
um am a little concerned about what we
did with the with the prison just
because we did give them 10 million but
that's just sort of that's not enough I
don't think to get them going with their
designing work
I thought they said during the um
hearing that it was or during the work
session that was 25 million but I didn't
know if we could get them to give us a
finer number
representative McGuire you shared that
discussion to you
have any thoughts
yeah I mean I mean I realize it's more
money yes
um I just be curious
right they did ask for they did say that
designing a prison was more like a 20 or
25 million dollar thing than a 10 right
so if we wanted to just fully fund the
design but not the prison we'd have to
take the 10 that's
not on the sheet but it's in there and
make it 20 or something like that so
we'd we'd need a
to to give back some of this money right
so I mean my only thought was that we
would get a clearer indication from them
I mean he was speaking off the cuff when
he was here
at least we could consider it I mean
honestly my other thought is I might
talk to Public Works
um
2 and see what's happening over there
because a lot of times when we're going
to take on a big project what we do is
we fund the design and Engineering to
get things going it probably really
should be there it's a capital yeah I
mean I think so too but so but the
starting point is we should get a good
number
did I make a
represent Griffin
you know I
I served a long time at the local level
as a as a selectman
and I learned early on
what whatever you put in the Warren
article is what it's going to cost
and
if you're going to raise that figure
really have to
focus on
getting it done
that you know at a reasonable price
if if you over fund it
that's what it will cost
I mean I I agree but I think there's
something to be said for the number of
square feet that's what he was basing it
on let's just see what they say yeah
because 10 million dollars is still a
pretty hefty price tag I know yeah but
it's not there's no Precision here
all right well
that being said Mike and Melissa just
could reach out to Corrections and
it really would be nice if it was around
10 million and not anymore
should we go back to hospital yes let's
uh we've got the handout that Mr Hoffman
gave us that stated 313 that's a shaded
document
and you can see that at least on the
first page that we've done
pretty well there and what we'll do is
just
um
let's see what PCB assistance that's the
for I'm sorry you know that's
the other top sheets a little less great
okay there we go
so 37 weren't we going to get something
as far as language Mike or Melissa on
that
PCB
assistance
I think like I don't know what you were
going to say but maybe what the chair is
thinking about is that I had asked
director wimsat about maybe being able
to use some of the PCB money also for
pfas but that
discussion didn't really proceed because
this is really a water issue and not a
waste management issue so I I don't
think there's anything happening on that
at this point I think their inclination
was they wanted to leave it for pcbs
that's what you were thinking of it was
that's what I guess I was thinking of
represent Maguire yeah this is if you
remember I I spoke to the chair of the
resources committee which is if this was
a bill that's where it would go
and he he thinks that number one it's
not super urgent it should he thinks it
should be a bill next year because it
didn't have enough detail in it
um so so I don't think we should be
creating a brand new section in Des
or a new fund or whatever this does
without the resources committee seeing
it as a bill and then sending it on to
us so you know my suggestion would be to
leave at least leave the 6 million
unspent try to come up with you know if
you want an earmark or or a thought that
that at the end of the day we'll have
we'll have the 6 million if it comes in
as a bill next year this is a problem
that there hasn't been more pfas PCB e
since 1977 so therefore one more year
doesn't seem like
you know it makes much of a difference
so other other thoughts
representative evil
grassy sake I you weren't here during
the discussion I think so what happened
was there was a settlement I forget with
whom on on the pcbs and in the rush to
do the settlement there wasn't a
provision in there that said that the
money had to be used for PCB remediation
and what happened was all the money went
into the general fund and I I thought it
was 31 million so this what they're
saying here is that they want to use
some of the money for its intended
purpose and that is for PCB mitigation
my my problem with all is just that the
water person never really had a chance
to talk about it during the course of
the you know to talk about how acute a
problem is or or whatever
so I'm a little hesitant to wipe it out
at this point because I just feel like
we haven't had representing policy
discussion and I know representative
McGuire and I had a discussion about
this the other day is that most of the
PCB stuff you know yeah there hasn't
been any new contaminations over the
years but a lot of it is when when
construction or other things dredging in
particular happen is that these pcbs
tend to get
brought up from the sludge that's on the
bottom of a pond or a river
um you know where there is stagnant
water and then it ends up Downstream and
we've got significant issues
particularly in Great Bay where you have
shellfish Farms down there and and I
know we had a proposal from eversource a
couple years ago to lay a line and one
of the problems they were finding is as
they were digging down and dredging
areas we were getting PCB contaminations
that were occurring uh so and and it's
the same thing in other locations as
well there was a a
discussion about removing some old lines
uh old cable that is in Lake
Winnipesaukee and they said don't touch
it leave it there because if you touch
it you're going to have this issue
um this issue is out there
uh when it when it's going to happen we
don't know new constructions that's
occurring other things that are
occurring uh dredging which occurs
regularly
um it's going to raise its head and we
should have something ready for it when
it does and so I would agree you know
the money needs to be left there
um whether we we leave it in the budget
and then have resources come in with a
bill next year to establish this this
program
I don't have a problem with that I don't
think we're going to see anything you
can't say we're not going to see a
problem in the next 12 months but the
thing is is that
um
this you know I would say there's a good
chance we aren't going to see a problem
in the next 12 months but but you just
can't you can't say that because we
could have a problem and so the money
should be available we should have the
ability to react at a at a future date
represent cambrells thank you Mr chair
and my recollection was when I asked the
question it was not so much this money
would be used for mitigation as they
wanted to use it for research to study
other bodies of water that they didn't
have a lot of data on because for
example the Merrimack River there has
been well documented where the issues
are there
um but he was they were talking about
other bodies of water that they need to
try to discover could they be a problem
in the future having said that I agree
with both representative Grassley and
McGuire that this is something we could
hold the money until they provide a
proper Bill next year
all right represent Maguire so as I
understand that representative grassy
served three terms on resources so
perhaps he could submit a bill and take
it through the process
Etc
um in in next year so
all right Mike and Melissa clear on what
we are headed for on this
right so remove sections whatever this
is
37 38 and 39 but
tell our colleagues we we want to
um we want at least a Six Million Dollar
Plus at the end of the budget for this
purpose
Mr Hoffman when you say tell our
colleagues will that be part of just
informally that would be part of the
maybe the division one presentation when
they when we go through the house bill
too
sheets at the end yeah
so we'll need an explanation as far as
the money will remain but before the
money is
allocated or appropriated to such a fund
legislation has to be brought forward
with the guidance for the use of that
money
so
yeah I mean it's it's not particularly
easy because if this was a retirement
Bill we could always stick money in the
unfunded liability and then later pass a
bill that uh that increased the unfunded
liability in a certain way right and and
so we can prepay such bills but in this
area you really can't so easily
it comes out of the rainy day fund
exactly or so or on
unallocated balance or whatever
see I was reading the sections
um
and the way it's set up it also allows
for any gifts donations of money federal
grants
um
it also it appears to be we might be
making this a little more confusing than
it has to be but
well and
there is six million here it didn't have
to be six to create it this time around
we could leave 37.38 but we could take
out the appropriation which is in
uh
38 dice
see because we there's
there's a creation there's the authority
so the commissioner can apply for and
accept funds but then you've got 38
which is the appropriation of 6 million
um and we could just reduce the
appropriation still like I mean that
takes 5 million and it gives them
something to start with there could be a
solution in the world next session with
our understanding that it will be coming
asking
all right well everyone's good with that
reduce it by 5 million leave the
existing language in there which I think
is probably good to lead the language
it's a little clearer next session yeah
we'll put a footnote in representative
grassy this will be something new a
footnote naming the legislator
responsible not
okay so that we've got those three items
taken care of
do we have a strawberry straw poll on
that uh 37.38
um
and I guess 39 okay and they're reducing
the appropriation from six to one
million
show a hands everyone okay with that
gineanomas
all right moving right along down to 42.
new subdivision historic housing
preservation tax credit
uh representative Sweeney I see was
going to look at some of that invest
below
oh I know it's we're going to wait for
Ways and Means I see the note here yep
who is going to do that Ways and Means
reach out was that
to me
was it
I know he was going to do the others
with um invest and
all right we can we'll skip over that
wait for
so moving down I guess the next one is
83 84. that's a crystal McCall I'm sorry
I skipped one here yeah 75 75.
we were wondering about the Arca money
oh yeah that's
on the
best New Hampshire
Sweeney's work uh Joe is gonna get some
information on that we have a handout
um
Karen umberger
oh and which one
on the invest New Hampshire okay
we could we can wait until Joe you know
represents Sweeney
gets you hopefully he's successful today
with this election or tomorrow oh is it
today tomorrow tomorrow
in the snow
I guess so I would just
yeah I just I've found that if we talk
about an issue we get the handle if we
don't it gets lost you know
we have so many papers but you're
welcome if you will like it but I found
it it generally if we wait
um there's just so many papers and it
gets lost so I just on the on the invest
representative Sweeney looking into
with funding stream right
I mean the other thing is that all this
was paid for with arpa before and I
don't know what the intentions are with
arpa at this point I don't know if
that's something
could ask
yeah well I think representative Sweeney
was going to try to get the answers to
all of that stuff for us
if my name is sure
um you know one of the thoughts I had
driving home I was thinking about this
Fund in particular is that the
investment New Hampshire money is this
under the governor's office and does he
have basically the control as far as the
council to dispense this money I believe
so and so that may be you know we've got
the political sensitivities there of of
moving that money from his Department
over to New Hampshire housing if I think
that was one of the discussions that
representative Sweeney and I had talked
about to put the administration of the
money over there instead of having it in
the governor's office
um and so you know that's something that
would we would have to discuss
uh but uh yeah I I thought it was a good
idea you know if New Hampshire housing
is willing to take on that
responsibility but we'd have to take a
look at what their Charter says as well
so
yeah and as representative evil said it
was all federal in the past and now it's
General so it makes a huge difference to
us being General funds of course 55
million dollars collectively right it
was a hundred million before of Arthur
right it was all on it right yeah
all right I apologize I skipped over uh
section 75 that was Granite place that
was right you were gonna someone's gonna
check on arpa for that which I would
um I have an email out to commissioner
Caswell on that question if the arpa
funds can be used for this
all right so then I guess
we can go down to 83. yeah and we were
waiting for dncr yeah
so work workers compensation that's one
15.
I heard from
former Senate President Bragdon on this
and if he's watching it's a good time to
come and speak to us uh he'd like to
talk to us about that workman's comp is
should we
he's pretty familiar with it and I guess
it has to do with a lot of
issues of people being disabled and
being able to hire those people not
being forced to pick up some liability
should they be hurt on the job so
uh Mr Bragdon would like to speak to us
on that representative yeah and I
haven't heard back from representative
infantine I can make a note to call him
again
okay this says representative rule
across the labor
I'm not sure where that came from
so it's
you do we know where that was me yes
represents representative wall yeah it
should be representative McGuire I guess
or maybe Mike has maybe I had it wrong
in my notes I thought she offered you
Jules Schultz still the wrong name yeah
because I know right person wrong name
yeah so representative McGuire will
reach out to the chair of Labor I
already have but I haven't gotten the
response okay thanks
doe is coming in
um
representative McGuire I heard an um so
so section
um
State Library so that's different than
the McAuliffe
well that's all resources they're coming
in so we want them to make a pitch for
these two things is that the idea okay
thank you yeah they should be in do we
have a specific date Melissa I know they
had to cancel but is it
tomorrow
I can check but we think it's tomorrow
okay
thanks a snowstorm
we're all staying over tonight is that
right everybody's so yeah tomorrow yeah
so yeah tomorrow doesn't sound like a
good day and you know we we did receive
an invitation from the governor to be at
his office tomorrow morning at eight
o'clock or something so
I think that might not yeah
Okay so
you saw the
I guess the next one is 139 that was
Public Utilities representative Maguire
again when you were
sharing that we we're gonna have them
come back there's a lot here for
ever yeah I really don't think we got to
this
I think I can answer that one yeah
energy
consumer Advocate they all came in
before we had House Bill 2. oh that's
right I invited him back I think it was
Thursday or Friday last week that you
would be interested in discussing how to
spill two sections with them that's
right
all right um
yeah we'll check with Janet see if
there's a I think that was out of that
oh
yeah I didn't
um I wasn't that uh impressed by the
consumer Advocate that I didn't I didn't
think these extra positions I mean this
is more of a personal thing but it's
also with two more positions right yeah
he was coming in to talk about that
specifically I thought
I think it's almost fair to talk
okay I mean he did talk about a little
bit yeah
it was to go to Regional meetings or
something like that yeah
all right so we'll make sure that
we have a date for them to come in
so going down here new paragraph
s
yeah I guess I'll have to look at the
full book here
these other
s these others like 140 surgical
benefits
so going down to one I think
let's see
oh this was doit 179
so help us out here Mike or Melissa so
the break between Department of energy I
see 147 179 so 179 budget Appropriations
transfer Authority 179 is uh doh
language that we see every year
concerning
um limitations on transfers from certain
expenditure classes
uh this year they're adding indirect
costs bond insurance and Property and
Casualty Insurance
and I'm drawing a blanket on this one
yeah for these particular class lines
um agencies can't transfer for other
purposes
can cannot cannot and they're asking for
Ken
no this would just keep the language
that we see every year it's the section
that one of the sections that repeats
but it adds those three bolded
expenditure classes okay
so any representing Kimbrell's so is
there a financial impact
let's make this change uh not really it
protects like information technology
they have this fairly involved
allocation across All State agencies and
if
if an agency were to transfer money out
of there and not have it available it
would throw the whole thing out of wax
so
um similar for indirect costs there's a
certain portion you know when an agency
receives federal funds
um the state is allowed to set aside a
certain amount for indirect costs
so
that's restricted you wouldn't want to
have that money sitting there and be
used for
something else okay so that's kind of
the theme for all of these sounds I
guess we're good everybody yeah
179.
one so
it looks like that's it's the same
language EX
is
so 180 there's certain classes that
this would allow to be for the biennium
and not lapse at the end of the first
year yeah
and that we've done before right correct
yeah okay that's right so 180 check that
off
foreign
the same language reoccurring and for
medical and surgical benefits
that's true except this year they're
adding that it shows online lapsing
and that would have to do with the uh
retiree and employee and retiree Health
accounts
because they have that bond to cover
claims and administer the benefits
we represent McGuire
everybody okay
all right so 181 salary adjustment fund
I'm sorry
salary adjustment fund is always existed
this would change
um
certification of the director of
personnel to the commissioner
and it specifies at the end legally
authorized salaries
and requires a report to governor and
Council
so a certain General funding agencies
for one reason or another
have left over money someone may retire
and they hire someone at a lower salary
um other agencies May hire someone in a
higher salary than expected
this fund allows those agencies that
have extra
appropriation to contribute and those
that need a little bit
to draw on
it keep it keeps
agencies operating and
provides
a way to cover those circumstances but
in no in no case does the states spend
more than it's appropriated for salaries
and benefits
that sounds okay to me is that much
different than what's in RSA 98 which is
being deleted
no let me uh yeah let's look at
foreign
because in the fiscal committee we get a
report
similar to
this
so
98 does
we'll have to follow up because when we
look at RSA 98 it says it's repealed
already so interesting so maybe that's
why yeah yeah so there's no section so
it's cleaning up the reference yeah
all right so this should be I'm okay
with that
everybody okay with that yeah
employee benefit adjustment account
see that's
similar to the previous explanation but
for the benefit class lines
salary is for the salary class lines
so here's yeah yeah so they're taking
out subject to the approval of governor
and Council
and then just giving an annual
information
it's all right with me
the government wants it the governor
doesn't want to approve something yeah
why not let them we won't be here
that's true
seems okay
Mike and Melissa any reason why we
should have somebody look at this I know
the governor and Council being taken
away from
the so-called oversight role
I wouldn't be too concerned because the
reporting requirement
s
they've got the report
okay I guess there's no
problem okay
so 184
budget office
184 is just changing that title
from the
budget director to the budget officer
who shall
our officers paid differently than
directors right
um
well there's a Governor's budget
director
and there's a position in administrative
services
budget office that heads up that budget
unit and there are two different
positions and I I suppose this is just
to eliminate any confusion between the
two all right so I guess we're
good with that and then of course it
moves down into 185
and there's a
change I'm just curious Mike how do and
Melissa
how do they divvy up costs now with this
new language
it seems to make sense the language
that's old and
I mean it looks to me like it's just
more specific
yes
right which should sell out yeah I mean
I think it looks everybody okay with
that 185 I am
okay a 186 Appropriations Department
of administrative Services technology
upgrade
so that's interesting
Mike of Melissa why wasn't this
in their budget and House Bill one or
what do they have for
could you put your fingers on it quickly
more quickly than we could
because usually upgrades are in the
their budget or yeah and we can look
into as it's not into their budget but
just a reminder of what this was this
was to upgrade the state's essential
budgeting system I think right now it's
held on servers and it was to upgraded
to the newest version and put it in the
cloud
um
but I can find out why it wasn't in
their budget but it was a I remember it
was a pretty serious ask from the
commissioner
well because it's a 2023 item that's not
2024 that's why
that's correct yeah
I mean they did they did talk about how
their their computer system was pretty
ancient and they you know yeah I kind of
just I guess I was assuming they had it
I saw a fairly significant line in their
budget yeah you would have thought so I
just
could we get a little more detail on
that and I thought they had
they spoke of the upgrade in their
presentation to us so I just
make sure we're not like adding too many
things here
okay that's 186.
yeah I'll try to get some more
information it's a lot of money
so what do we have 188
Commission on Aging let's see
oh this is where they're going to have a
youth found right for you
let's see
this is where they're having trouble
getting people right yeah I think 189 is
fine
so 189
188 and 189 are fine it's
everybody okay with that 188 189.
section 190 is removing language that
authorize the governor to draw warrant
since it's in the operating budget now
that language is no longer needed
okay that's easy then
insert following a new paragraph
yep
independent agency administratively
attached it looks like that 191 we okay
with that
yeah
and then this one's gonna get duties
192.
yeah
all right
so
190 to 192. yeah it looks like it
193 you took care of that representative
McGuire let me see
yeah with something gave them everything
they wanted and then some
I ought to take more time off yeah
yeah they seem to be seriously yeah they
definitely are yeah
yeah they got the National Guard
so what are your thoughts on this
barking
spend such funding as appropriated
Mike and Melissa what type of funding
are they talking about what did they
have aligned somewhere that
funding is appropriated
for additional parking we'll have to
look through the budget see if we can
find an appropriation for that memory I
think was somewhere in the neighborhood
of twenty twenty five thousand dollars
and it's in it's been in past budgets
of course what they don't use will Labs
back to the general fund
but we'll get an answer on the dollar
amount
maybe just kind of curious
the dollar amount might be it's
uncomfortable having a completely open
yeah I know well you could cap it maybe
or something
we asked to represent Griffin I'm not
sure I rarely understand what this is
all about
someone give us a summary
yeah Mike Melissa
the quick answer is not everyone has a
space so they have to park in metered
spaces for
um it's probably about
300 yards up that way
to a residential street without meters
and then they have
traffic issues up in those areas
um especially in the winter when there's
snow Banks and kids trying to walk to
school that sort of thing
represent Maguire so does this pay for
like spaces in the parking Concord
parking garage and School Street and
things like that is that
yeah see they're metered or spots in the
garage if they're available a lot of the
garage spots are reserved too
are these people that might otherwise
Park you know like when we don't have
session days they can park in the
legislative garage and yes stuff like
that yes okay
okay
does all we also pay the city of Concord
don't we uh for that land with a parking
garage is no
I'm not sure what the terms of that
lease are there's a it's like a hundred
year lease I think but
there is a payment in lieu of taxes to
the city for uh all the properties that
they aren't able to collect property tax
on
all right
thanks representative Griffin
my understanding on store street is not
what you're talking about yeah is that
they have the air rates
but they don't have the ground rates
under the building
maybe right yeah I think that's right
okay so next we go down to the
compensation for state employees that's
a
roughly 100 million dollars for the
biennium
yeah
do we ever get anything from the
Department of administrative services
for the breakdown for classified and
non-classified I know they were hoping
to come in right maybe today yes I had
invited them in for 10 o'clock today and
I didn't get a confirmation on that but
I just sent them after 10 o'clock
another email saying can you let me know
what's a good time to come in because
they wanted to work out the details a
little bit more and discuss what they
had had so far on that breakdown between
unclassified and classified in the
different branches and the cost okay
so we'll hold on that and it takes us
through
267 I believe that's agriculture
Advisory Board
yeah so Melissa when you ask a question
um they said something about these
tables being having diagonals right that
that like a GG Step One is the same
thing as a eff step two or something you
know something like that but I don't
really see that
so would you ask him about that sure and
I'm looking on page 72
oh I see what you're saying
yes I will ask about that it typically
did working in the executive branch it
used to be a diagonal line to that so I
will ask on that thank you thanks
Melissa
all right so
267. I believe is the next what does it
beat me
it's what's that what page page number
eight 58.
I'm 258.
oh the repealed Department of oh yeah he
remember he explained that that was all
covid related and unnecessary now and
say
well thanks for catching that let's see
258.
what about 267.
we got to go to 250. the clerk backed us
up the sound of something
stuck in between the pay raises
not doing anything
yeah we have to agree on 258. these were
the things that he said were covet
related and no longer applicable yeah so
on page 83
258.
so I guess if we don't need them anymore
we can get rid of 250 checkoff 250a
everyone okay with that
so 259 I have a note um
says Carol on here so I must have
okay
yeah
so Carolyn Melissa have been working on
all the oplc stuff and I think tomorrow
if we have time is
she could come in and discuss it all
right
you want to set that up I think you're
spending some time with her right
assuming we're in tomorrow oh yeah yeah
I don't think we'll probably be in
tomorrow by the sounds yeah no
in New London
so Friday yeah
two or three inches
plus rain maybe
all right so then then I guess Friday
yeah you want to arrange that yeah so so
she'll
they've have extensive Amendment for
House Bill too and and uh they'll have a
highlight sheet of what the changes are
so yeah
um so if we need to ask her about this
we could do it at the same time
all right we'll mention it to Janet she
can put it on the calendar for uh Friday
9 30 okay Jan
yeah 9 30. I think so
representative McGuire the other
representative I'll check just to make
sure but yeah okay
maybe I'll text thank you it actually
looks really simple they're just
it just says to
which shall include but not be limited
to
they were just
okay
all right you want to wait yeah okay now
we already have Friday at 9 30 but maybe
it just was it's just general work
session okay okay
so Workforce Development 216. oh no so
it would have to be Friday afternoon
there's jail car Friday morning
okay so um Friday one o'clock
one o'clock Mike Melissa
oh I see okay 258.
oh yeah I do have that from
Carol for all the way to
262.
okay
Broadband infrastructure bonds to 63.
are these just simple changes Melissa
looks so good
yes when they created the department of
energy there were certain
pieces of the office of a strategic
initiatives that land in other places
and this cleans up the language to the
current structure
all right everybody okay with that
tax on meals and rooms population
figures
264.
section 265 265.
next one's an appropriation okay so this
is too an appropriation
that Department's still
we can still do to come in yeah we can
wait for them
so resource is it coming in later this
week so we can talk to them about the
appropriation they're scheduled to come
in tomorrow at 9 30.
I guess you are spending the night here
representative I think I can make it but
I live close so yeah
okay
267 just looks like
so to the agricultural Advisory Board
everybody okay with that
I think the commissioner
of Agriculture mentioned that
as well
267 Melissa all said
.
a lot this when the Attorney General
was in he talked about some Physicians
medical examiner type positions that
they had contracted before and now are
going to be
State positions
271 takes an existing position and
reclassifies it to be the
deputy chief forensic investigator
it will use whatever Appropriations are
there
the salary will be determined by review
from that joint legislative committee
and then the person in the position will
be offered that
the incumbent will be offered if they're
qualified will be up for the new
position
so 270 271 272
are we okay with those
I am
represent grass seal
everybody
no no
I'm sorry the the one thing in the
Attorney General's office that I thought
were possibly overspending on and
they're doing it deliberately it was the
Cold Case area oh that's right yeah yeah
they were hiring what one more person
for Cold Case something like that yeah
and it just seemed to be to me to be a
low low benefit for you know operation
but who knows Melissa Mr Hoffman we've
never acted on the Attorney General's
additional request the f I had one or
two more folks yes
yep I have another when we get to that I
have a list of all the additional
requests
well we could take up I do recall
represent McGuire in the Cold Case unit
had some concerns but that's not this no
no but it reminded him of the okay
so she's certainly won 272. I think
we're good are you good with us
so solicitor general
that looks like clean up to me when the
Attorney General was in and
um going over that handout with the
organizational chart he talked about the
solicitor general being
um
placed in the division to you know for
the for the the boundaries between the
types of
Legal Services they provide
seem to recall some of that are we okay
with 273 and then moving on to 274
division of legal counsel amended so
yeah they're renaming the transportation
Construction
okay
in Department of Justice name change
check
so I had a question Mr Hoffman a
question mark next to 276 why would that
be
foreign
as I understand it it's a function that
they've chosen to reap to put in uh
Department of Health and Human Services
instead of Justice
maybe it was did we ever do we know that
that's what the Department of Health and
Human Services is okay with maybe that
was my question I've uh made Kevin
Ripple aware of this so when he works
with division three
um okay well the two of us will know
whether everybody's in agreement and
will represent McGuire if I had to make
a guess I would think that HHS often has
access to matching funds for things
Federal matching funds and this could be
a a trick that way
I guess we can check it off as Mike is
reached out to Mr Ripple there's a
problem we can come back to it but we're
thinking about um
a news section charitable Trust 277.
[Music]
so 277 when you receive a payment like a
credit card or debit card payment the
providers charge you a little fee this
would allow the state the Attorney
General's office to recover that charge
we all okay with a new fee
well I think it's moving part of an
existence yeah
but
but why were they
I mean why did they need it because
they're all funded with their budget
well actually it may be yeah I think it
is
be for uh any registration annual report
notice and document
oh okay they wanted to think they want
the three percent yeah yeah right for
the credit card
the secretary of state does it
registry does
it right I think that's all right
all right so we're okay with that
gonna break it in
section 278 cleans up old language
because they no longer require people to
appear at the State House
okay
Victim Assistance Program
so 279 no more than 30 percent of the
money
15 must not have been up
so that would obviously mean less money
to the folks
seeking assistance I think we need an
argument
we want to eliminate it or get more
information let them make a case okay
Mike if Melissa could just reach out and
and once again I
is this a case where they're they're
like hiring Consultants or something I
mean wouldn't all the people doing the
assistance doing the administration
already
have salaries and stuff like
they also get
receipt funds from other sources
this is I believe Mike Melissa correct
certainly correct me if I'm wrong I
should just let you describe it but this
is within the Attorney General's office
right as someone's a victim of a crime
there's money given to them towards
their
the ability to raise more money there is
money that comes in but Mike you
probably do so the victims assistance
fund uh receives money from certain uh
penalty assessment or or court fees
um a portion of that money goes into
victims assistance fund
um
and then like you said it goes out to
help victims of crimes
so this would just allow them to cover
more of their costs up to 30 percent
instead of up to 15 but we can follow up
and get some numbers
yeah because certainly the victims that
this is supposed to have will be losing
funds this happens not necessarily
that's the thing you've got to see
where's the diminishing returns which
means that they're saying they're not
getting all the funds that you're
getting
but they're not being able to spend the
time together get it and so they're not
they're not recouping as much money as
they should towards the fund that's what
we've got to find out and I think they
also provide an annual report so I'll
see if I can get a copy of that yeah
representative McGuire yeah so
but my point is it if everyone who works
for the Attorney General's office is
already in the budget and already gets a
salary from the general fund what sort
of and there's somebody who this is
their job right to work this area
how would they spend this money right I
mean when it says used for the costs
aren't the costs sort of already in the
budget
you know that's
yes and I'm sure that they somehow
allocate the person's time between
programs and maybe they've just
determined yeah so maybe it's in the
budget as other funds right this is
another type item yeah we'll get the
details yeah thank you thanks Michael
so 280
um
administration of benefit payments to
existing benefits yes representative
the point is if we took this out that
might raise general fund Appropriations
right it's because if the budget already
says this guy's getting a salary from
other and we take this out now he's got
to be paid from the general fund right
yeah every time
all right so 280. let's get nervous when
I suck my stuff but it's just 40 000. so
there was a a benefit provided to uh
surviving spouses
that was uh repealed in 2014
but there are still two spouses alive oh
and this benefit this would fund
um their benefit whatever it is
all right any questions
on there are we okay with that small
all right so we check off 280 then
281 business Finance Authority
so this is increasing there
amount that they can loan I believe
Mr Hoffman any thoughts
they've come in before for this too if
they are increasing this before there's
a the threshold cap on certain
state-backed borrowing
and I believe this was like the peace
Development Authority used some of this
um environmentally Authority when they
redeveloped and then they paid the state
back so this increases it from
115 million to 200 million
so the last time was May of 2015.
any problem with that
you know let's all set everybody
it's not my favorite I know I was I saw
you sat back on this one getting away
from the mic yeah I mean I don't think
we should have these kind of programs
that's mine this is like
corporate welfare
didn't the balsams go after some of this
money wasn't when that
um
gentleman was in
anyway
but changing but the budget is not the
place to discuss that right I mean the
police discussing this with a bill a
separate bill
yeah go ahead I think the blossoms did
seek some sort of State backed
um borrowing
I think they didn't get it because it
was yeah I don't remember all the
details
this is money that's helped a number of
communities attract businesses you know
when we took a look at saffron
um in Rochester we would competed with
North Carolina
and the business Finance Authority was
one place that we were able to get some
loans to help them build their facility
uh its loans they're going to get paid
back
um and it's not like some of these other
loans we talked about where yeah maybe
we'll get it one of these days you're
going to get it back uh and it was out
helped us attract them to the state of
New Hampshire instead of going to North
Carolina
um you know we used Tax incentives and
business loans once we've got these
things in place that was the package
that they they accepted to come to New
Hampshire
Mr Hoffman could we get something from
them
um
how much they have outstanding in loans
if there's been any defaults
and what their interest rate their
present interest rate is that would be
helpful I think Miss representative
gliders have some good points as does
represent a grassy but I think we need
some more information
in 200 million dollars is a lot of money
that's a pretty significant jump
thanks guys
my children
but it's still a guarantee it possibly
affects the state's credit running
so maybe a comment from the treasurer
would be in order it said it it does it
indebtedness of the state the state
backs this the state backing of this
available
you okay with that yeah can we could we
ask the state treasurer to comment on
this section yeah thanks
professional licensure we know where
that is Friday
be there or be square
new sections or ad dive
Down The House bill 300.
yeah so what this was when we took our
vote to include it in the budget we have
to have an amendment and it had an
expense associated with it so that would
be included in the amendment
and that was like what 90 somewhat
thousand a year for that
to prove that we're gonna check that off
so
News section new section Mike and
Melissa the the 300 well of an amendment
for that
yes so we have the uh
oh the white yeah there's a another
request related to 300 that we haven't
received back yet uh same but not that
they're late we just asked for it Friday
evening so right we'll sing for the next
one
that was a house
no but this is a different one yeah this
was the other one this was the pool boys
band
because to administer it they needed the
money
these are how it's one new position
these are house bills we've already
talked about decided to accept by
putting them into the budget right right
so the bills themselves will be retained
right and then and then next to your itl
because it's they're no longer
right so that's it that's right
and we just we just call them new
because we don't have a section number
for the bill right we just got to get
the amount
I saw this on the back page seven
there's two that we're just waiting for
an amendment on the first two
do we have the Lynn Oprah Amendment mic
that I was under my name for the liquor
commissioner we want to
I I don't have it back in drafting yet
so just for those that you may be
familiar it's always been an issue
with the division and the fiscal
committee about the closure of liquor
stores representative Ober when she was
chair ahead of
um
section in the budget that the Senate
removed two years ago to require the
Liquor Commission to come to both a
fiscal committee and the governed
Council for the closure and that's what
this amendment is with my name on the
bottom is the same language to have them
at least notify Us in advance so there
can be some public discussion about
closure versus right now they're
required to come to the fiscal committee
after the fact to let us know which
doesn't make a lot of sense
representative umberger was also very
supportive of notification again so the
public is aware of a closing
and I think that's it oh just
just on liquor just did
a budget or am I streaming that I think
it's it was in the capital wasn't it
Mike it is in capital I know but I
thought you saw it in okay I think when
the uh
Governor presented to house finance the
whole committee he mentioned the liquor
store
um
I know it's in it is I just didn't want
I want to make sure there wasn't
duplication no duplication it is in the
capital budget
yes
so do we know from retirement when we
might see them as far as
issue of
House Bill 571 that was discussed this
morning they give us any indication when
they might have some numbers
we don't have an exact answer I know
he's working it I did a quick
calculation while we were in here
because he gave the breakdown just if
everybody was at the maximum so that
five percent of fifty thousand and the
10 of 50 000 based on the years so that
I think the maximum amount if it was a
one-time payment would be
13.25 million so
it will be under that amount okay based
on it just to give you a rough ballpark
of where you're at thanks so much that's
very helpful Melissa you're welcome so
we're we're doing fairly well here I
guess thanks to you guys back there
so we'll
break and come back at one
um
we don't have a lot left of course we
have the full public hearing at two
o'clock so
was there any reason for us to come back
Mike other than we might get something
from somebody
I'll reach out to um
Mr bragged until I'll give him a call
and suggest Maybe
be here at one o'clock to discuss the
workman's comp issue that
we passed over today earlier
other than that representative mcguardia
yeah I I I'd like to kind of just we
have a very long list of bills and
especially we're going to exact a lot on
Wednesday so I may be just go through
them once more just to make remind
ourselves what's in them oh absolutely
that's not a bad idea at all yeah so
we'll be back here no matter what at one
o'clock
his age 1850s on that hb50 is on that
list yeah
we have a lot of bills that take up
um
yeah they probably the municipal
Association
yeah they usually send out a notice or
Retirement Systems to everybody it's a
complete package there okay
no that's the speaker yeah
foreign
thank you
okay
foreign
thank you
yes
you've taken notes in life
I couldn't get any volunteers
so um Mr Bragdon is gonna
come to the table and speak to us about
a section of house bill 2. dealing with
workman's comp I appreciate you uh being
willing to
add some history to this and
Mr Hoffman what section or Melissa is
this an hb2 I mean we have hardly
anything left so it should be easy to
find
no
oh 115 okay
115 representative Griffin's right page
40.
foreign
all right sir if you could identify
yourself and I think we can spell your
last name well hopefully uh thank you uh
Mr chairman for the record Peter Bragdon
b-r-a-g-d-o-n a recovering state
legislator uh also a uh lobbyist with
pretty strategies uh here today
representing a company called comp Sigma
which is a company that specializes in
helping self-insured companies and small
companies form groups uh in the area of
workers compensation we represent or we
have in our trust uh over 400 New
Hampshire companies uh in three
different trusts manufacturers
um Healthcare and Human Services and
lumber which is our longest standing one
so anyone involved in Industries in
those ways are involved more than 400
companies with uh yesterday until they
told me there were 28 000 employees in
these companies that are covered by our
workers comp programs and today they
told me they just brought in another one
with six employees so now we're at
twenty eight thousand and six employees
uh these are self-insured which means
that and by the way also in the back is
Dan Bennett with New Hampshire auto
dealers if there's any questions later
on uh they also have uh hundreds of
companies and thousands of employees
that they cover through their
self-insured workers comp trust and I've
also spoken with New Hampshire Municipal
Association uh all town cities school
districts in the state are self-insured
for workers compensation through primex
also very concerned about the repeal of
the second injury fund uh basically
under especially a self-insured model
the companies pulled together not only
to pull their resources but to take a
proactive approach to safety if you join
one of the trusts that my client runs uh
you were forced to have the loss control
people from the company come visit you
and work with you to find ways to reduce
your claims a typical insurance company
may not be as concerned about that
because they make their money from the
premiums no matter what the premiums are
as long as they win the bid if you're a
member of a self-insured trust you have
a self-interest in lowering those claims
not only because you get money back for
some of the the claims but your claims
and your premiums in the future are
based on your experience what's happened
in the past so the example was giving me
the day of someone who blows out their
knee let's say uh at work blow with the
knee it costs a hundred thousand dollars
to repair it you know for lack of a
better term repair it under the second
injury fund if you had blown out your
knee somewhere else previously and they
do all the calculations and they
determine that okay the the new employer
is responsible for fifteen thousand
dollars of that hundred the eighty five
thousand but balance gets covered by the
second injury fund but the bigger term
impact of that is further down the road
that company that employed that person
they're only charged on the workers comp
experience calculations a fifteen
thousand dollar loss rather than a
hundred thousand dollar loss so the
employee is made whole and I should
point out by the way that strangely
enough the uh the trial lawyers or the
association for justice uh usually are
adversary in any workers comp situation
they represent the employee we represent
the employer they agree with us that
getting rid of the second injury fund is
a bad idea yeah and I guess I'll also
point out this is a major policy issue
it shouldn't be tucked into the budget
in fact if you look at the summary page
of the budget where it lists out all the
things in the budget it doesn't say the
second injury fund is in there so we
didn't find out until I think Friday of
last week that it was in there
the bullet point says uh let's see the
bullet point says that a redirects
workers comp funds from the general fund
to the Department of Labor restricted
fund that makes sense and makes changes
to the employer insurance carrier
reimbursement process it doesn't say get
rid of the second injury fund so uh big
picture this is a huge policy issue it
really deserves its own bill with a
substantive policy debate on both sides
but in reality this saves New Hampshire
employers a lot of money both in the
short term on the claims that happen as
they happen but when your mods start
they call it the mod your experience
rating and workers comp starts going up
you pay for that for years so again we
represent twenty eight thousand and six
uh New Hampshire employees and over 400
companies and uh some of our board
members for our manufacturers you'll
recognize some of these names because I
look to see what township folks are from
uh so Gilbert block from Laconia Lakes
Region community services from Laconia
um a nadnock paper from Bennington when
I was in the Senate the folks from
Milford Lumber and Wilkins Lumber and PJ
Courier Lumber all involved with this
they all want to see this retained Kelly
Trucking up in Gorham Boys and Girls
Clubs uh the All the Boys and Girls
Clubs in the state are covered by
self-insured trust so I think it's in
all our interests to see this preserved
but at least have a substantive policy
debate about the merits and I think I
can wrap it up with with that I'd be
happy to answer any questions I used to
work for this company back before I as
soon as when I was in the Senate so
probably uh 15 to 20 years ago when I
first started in the Senate so I
remember enough to be dangerous but if
you have specific questions I'll try to
answer it or the folks behind me might
be able to questions for Mr Bragdon
represent Griffin well
you're telling us Rings true to me
because I served before I was in the
legislature I served as a Chief
Financial Officer for a number of
companies and I know how important
the broad rate is
to the premium
and uh
I did work for one company that was a
major Lumber wholesaler
so it was out of state but
um
I agree with everything you've said
basically
well I won't say anything else don't
ruin it right that's right
representative McGuire thank you Mr
chairman then thank you for coming
um
so
you said that this will save people a
lot of money if we keep it right but I
don't see how because isn't Insurance
um what's would save money is if there
were fewer injuries right where there's
going to be injuries there's going to be
expenses for for
um dealing with those injuries and
there's also going to be administrative
expenses to determine you know the size
of the injury whether it should be
funded all this sort of stuff but in a
sense doesn't this fund have expenses
right and so if you look at the big
picture
um by getting rid of it we get rid of
those particular expenses but we haven't
changed the number of injuries we
haven't changed that so so overall I
don't see how this saves any money to
keep it oh thank you for the question
that's a great question so yeah overall
big picture wise the amount of money
coming in and out uh is unchanged uh the
the second injury fund is funded I
Believe by an assessment on all workers
comp carries in the state a small
assessment and then for those with
second injuries it's almost like a high
risk pool in the health insurance Market
um and so especially when you're dealing
with a lot of smaller companies I think
in the testimony the Department of Labor
said that uh the New Hampshire the
Americans with disability Billy's acts
has kicked in since this was started and
maybe we don't need this as much anymore
but that only applies to companies with
more than 15 employees so a lot of these
small companies lumber companies
trucking companies uh have less than 15
employees they're small companies so one
catastrophic workers comp claim can shut
the company down so by spreading the
risk amongst all workers comp it
actually benefits uh it really benefits
everybody but especially those smaller
companies and those that are
self-insured and the purpose the reason
for enjoying self-insured is they want
to drive down that's how we help them
save money we work with them to drive
down the the cost of insurance by by
driving down the accident rates by
getting our loss control people in there
to recommend you should be lifting this
way you should be doing this you should
be doing that and to be a member of the
trust you have to follow those
directions or I don't say you get booted
out but uh it's uh you know less likely
to want you hanging around because
you're going to drive up everybody
else's rate
are there any further questions from Mr
Bragg
seeing none uh the division's pleasure
representative
I think it is a policy issue
and it should get back kicked back to a
policy committee I don't think it has
any business here or in HP
two
so representative Griffin is suggesting
through a motion that we eliminate
section 115.
is there a second to that
a second advice
and we'll just we'll just have a show of
hands if that's all right with the
division all those for removing
okay thanks thanks Mr Bragdon thank you
all used to be a time I got a vote when
I was in one of these rooms but that's
that was a long time ago
oh yeah represent McGuire is a comic if
you would like to introduce legislation
I I would say surely the governor has
some friends in the legislature who
could carry such legislation forward so
yeah
all right thanks thank you for coming
all right another one off-road list
Bites the Dust
so representative McGuire had a good
suggestion since we don't have a lot of
time before we have to be across the
street but just to touch on the bills
and
all of you should have gotten a copy of
the
house bills before financing as you can
see division one is probably
more than blessed with the majority but
we've gotten through just about all of
them but they're only five being taken
up Wednesday
and uh
the first one being
house bill 50.
and uh
representative McGuire is cast to speak
to that as he made the motion of ought
to pass that's amended yeah so on this
one my suggestion would to the whole
committee will be so so I've already
we've already written the blurb we've
already decided off to pass with
Amendment the amendment changes the bill
significantly in the sense that it
um adds money to the unfunded liability
rather than sending it back to towns
specifically so the same people
effectively are being helped in the
sense that
um
by adding money to the unfunded
liability you're going to reduce the
long-term cost to towns in the similar
proportion to what the bill does but it
spreads it out and and does it in a way
that doesn't
um encourage them to hire
faster than they would otherwise
but because it's such a big change you
know so so essentially we're rewriting
the bill we're spending the same amount
of money in the same general way but but
we're rewriting how it's done so my my
feeling is we should say hopefully get
the whole committee to say ought to pass
we send it to the house hopefully get
their approval and then at that point
table the bill before it goes to the
Senate and and add it to the budget
so
um I think that this should eventually
be in the budget in house bill 2.
um
but we should really get the approval of
the whole house for this change for the
for for the the change of policy if you
see what I mean
can you representative Griffin
foreign
basically saying it's not generic I
think it is generic Germaine Jermaine
uh no it's not
well right now it's carried in 2023
because we have sufficient funds
um so we'll have to be careful and
consider moving it into the budget
because right now it's being carried for
it funding in 23 and we have the funding
to do it it's a one-time payment
right so the the reason I'm I'm
suggesting tabling it after passing in
the house is to have more leverage to
get our way
with the Senate and the governor right
because if we simply let it go right you
know we say off the pass
I see a point you see what I mean yeah
but they could go to the Senate and they
could just itl they could say itl now
they've got 50 million to spend on
something else yeah no I see it right
but this is what we want to spend 50
million on and therefore you know we're
all converted I think yeah yeah well I
was just going to say in the Senate
isn't that how they do a lot of these
things they actually table things and
then roll them into the budget
absolutely so you just have to make sure
that people
believe that if we table it we will put
it in the budget
I mean that's
all right
well at least get it through the
committee Wednesday yeah I mean
it's on our sheet yeah it will be in the
budget so I mean we could just just so
the other option is just to say retain
right now
right and put it in the budget right but
I think if you yeah you say this is the
house position
absolutely that's that's what I think so
awesome it's a much better solution than
the original bill yeah because it could
it's it's the continues to help those
cities and towns over a period of years
it helps everybody the pension is
everybody and it's specifically going to
the retirement fund versus you know for
some other project in a community so
all right so next that the committee
will be taking up
311 which we've already held on that's
already in the budget so that's easy
those are the so-called Buco bucks
and then we have a 340 I'm sorry 384.
that's you
um yeah question on that one I I noticed
on the sheet it was changed from 25
million to 22 and a half
was there some did we get better
information no the reason that that is
we're taking 2.5 million from the
legislative budget
this is if there's more than 10 million
there so I see I mean are we reviewing
the legislative budget if they can't
come in until after the 24th oh yeah we
can still see it I think we should
so the clerk needs to catch up yeah
that's not a problem
so next we have 506 that's the uh rail
chill box tunnel on exit 4A that was
representative Maguire
oh
um
foreign
so originally that was
um
I guess that's just going to be itl
right so
so but if we send it back to the house
as an Ito and they turn us down and go
back to octopic I guess I don't see that
happening now the vote was eight to zero
it was my handwritten notes here okay
all right so it could even be on consent
Maybe
although Pearson probably take it off so
I don't know
[Laughter]
if it has an appropriation
no I did McGuire and uh he did yeah yeah
all right so I was just thinking that if
it should pass
the money should move to 2023. yeah
um but and so we maybe should have a
floor Amendment but but I think it's so
low low probability we don't have to
worry about it yeah depending on what
the full committee does Wednesday I
would think they'd probably follow our
advice it would not be on consent
because of the Appropriations
okay
and then the last one we have is um
555 and that was
bought to pass I don't have who
was eight to zero I'll have to check
this he was speaking to that
Janet's not feeling well so he'll we'll
get that probably uh
bright and early Wednesday who do you
have a record of who's I think I'm a
co-sponsor so I feel like it was
it might have been me
yeah I'm really feeling it yeah we're
all feeling it yeah
I mean this is an easy one yeah that's
it it probably actually has no effect
on the budget this year not this year
because I don't think it's a threshold
yeah
all right so that's it for what we have
as a division for Wednesday
and the others will be forthcoming
should we talk about the other division
one
we talked about the other division one
films because that it feels to me like
we could maybe we can't because we're
not in the calendar we can't act on them
but
no we it's you know they have to be
noticed if there's a house bill but if
it was strictly a budget but we can
certainly talk about anything we've got
a few minutes left just go over our list
yeah so the first one is 46 that was
ought to pass McGuire making the motion
five to one
okay
right because they took out the finance
stuff right so yeah
Okay so we've already talked about 50.
74. unearned
time unused or in time
that was itl representative Kimbrell I
think you've already given us a
blurb on that
FIFA
see what's happening we're still waiting
on it we're still thinking yes gotcha
now I thought we acted on
2 30.
no it's not noted on the sheet here
right I believe that was ought to pass
well no it's retained
this is going to go in the back yeah
right yeah yeah it's got a hospital two
amendment to add that you know
yes so do we know who made that
I don't recall not that it's that
important since we're putting it in the
budget but we'll should update the sheet
at some point
uh the
renewable energy credits
I had a note it was itl by McGuire
that's why I wrote that in there
what it was it was without
recommendation so and I was gonna but
that's right but I'm gonna do the OTP
right she'll write a blurb and I'll
write a blurb okay it has verbs will do
battle yeah exactly and it has no
physical impact
so it's just going to go back to the
house no limitation yes or whatever the
our committee ends up doing oh so evil
is going to do the I
not to pass
so the next one 269 250. oh I'm sorry
skip
we were asking for more that's right
it's detail for a fiscal look
and then um now we can do
269 that was Sweeney ought to pass this
amendment I think he's already given me
a blurb for that
the mitigation so and that retain is a
real live routine that's a real live
retained seven to zero I had my choir
that's
well we're going to study we're going to
study
ing
something
from the capital budget people
is that where we had the chairman come
in from public works that's right yeah
when DDS was here actually yeah
the problem is it's it's a really badly
written you know maybe a worthwhile
policy but the bill itself needs needs
help
so the
food waste spill at 300
and there's going to be an amendment to
add
two
position in there with about 90 some 1
000 right
we've already talked about 311
recruitment incentive program that was
uh ought to pass or the representative
Weiler
yeah that's right he yeah he did write
something up
is that the budget or no
um
it is
already in the budget
okay
it's 2000 years
so therefore we can just pass the bill
as is
um so it should go together
it should probably go together okay so
we'll say
hb2
okay this is a public notice 337.
not to pass represent Maguire
yeah this one can just go back to that
yeah
it didn't really have a
347 that was
goes to House Bill 2 and it was in the
court
operating budget for an additional judge
yeah
so therefore it's a retained yeah
but where are we do we have a specific
language Melissa or Mike that we're
going to add for that to make it very
clear that was going to be a land use
judge we had some discussion about that
language
and what was missing from hospital two
was the change of a number of Judges
okay
so you're going to take all that 347
land use language and put it in the
house okay
so our action is retained
yep did we vote on that
we did it I had just hb2 but I don't
think we did actually have a bow
we did accept the judicial branch budget
which included the additional judge
so should I move that would make you
happy absolutely all right I'll move
retain on House Bill 347 with the
intention of putting all the language
into the um into how skeletons seconded
by representative Griffin show of hands
are okay with that unanimous
okay okay so I don't you know what I
don't remember much about this one the
next one 379.
Indigent tenants
eviction it was must not have been any
money there what like uh is that could
anybody have any recollection of that
since since I voted for it yeah I know
yeah while nine to zero that just adds
language to the eviction notice
that says that service is from
um
I think it's New Hampshire civil Legal
Services
legal services are available to the
tenants when they're evicted and it
states that in the notice
so there's no cost
yeah all right
yeah I think this note here is isn't
very informative
on this because really this is when
you're someone's being evicted this adds
a sentence to the eviction notice saying
Legal Services may be available
right that's right yeah you made the
question why are we encouraging more
businesses yeah right because it's
expensive right yeah that's right but
anyways that's what it is okay thanks
next one is representative evil I've
already seen her very good blurb
now are you going to speak against that
representative
McGuire I know you were the one yeah
maybe if it's not you know when you see
my blur twenty four to one if it's 24 to
1 and I'll let it go but it's 24 to 23-2
maybe okay
I vote first so I'm going to vote again
and really I don't know why I vote first
you know it's my world
well here no it's not yeah but over
there somehow yeah well your division
one well it will be it will be the most
senior Republican voting first but
usually right now
yeah which I well that's right it will
be it will be Earth voting first well
I think it's a vice chair and full
committee and then it's the most senior
Republican after the Vice chair I think
that but they seem to skip Earth and go
to me so oh we ought to change that yeah
but
um
so parking Brad then we go down to
the transition okay 436 which we're
still reviewing anybody want to talk
about that at all representative
so again just a reminder we're waiting
for retirement to get some more
information back to us especially the
municipal impacts of this proposed
legislation is also is those of you
recall that an amendment was given to us
Friday so that's still unfold
we approved that member we approved the
amendments
yes
right but so we still need to make a
decision whether we're gonna
funded or because it's a significant
amount of money so I'm not going to talk
about that our strategy right with house
bill 436.
so
it's we're retaining it because
it's murky whether it affects towns and
if so how
okay
um but
it passed the house super strongly like
like 280 to 80 or something right so
um so therefore we really ought to do
something with it now it's possible that
everybody who voted for it didn't
realize that this is a 250 million
dollar item yeah
well we just said we're going to hold on
we're going to recommend to the
information I mean this is my plan so
is to recommend to the full committee
that we retain it but also that we add
the money for it to the unfunded
liability
to prove that we're in Earnest about
doing something in this area and
therefore if next year it comes out of
retain with an ought to pass in some
form we don't have to appropriate money
for it it'll be already spent in the in
the retirement system and and so
um and if worse comes to worse we've
spent money in the you know we've we've
we've put money towards the unfunded
liability so what's wrong with that
right so
anyway
my Approach on this is
there's a lot to it
it's very complex and the amendment
didn't do anything to make it easier
is going to need a study committee
you know long before the budget it's the
it's the house
I mean long it's it's going to take a
long time to figure this one out
the problem is the people affected are
starting to retire or getting close to
retirement
so I I tend to think we can be the
finance committee or maybe division one
can be the summer study committee for
this that's sort of what retain does
right and
and the way it's currently set up the
bill itself doesn't spend any money
until 2025. so it's okay to have it come
out in January
with some kind of recommendation yeah
we're on the same page okay that's an e
DNA done a lot of work on this already
or no well it did come to us from that
committee but I thought they had done
quite a bit of work
yeah although but not on the Amendments
right well not on the amendment but not
on the money just significant which
nobody had a clue
it's a financial commitment that once
started it goes to 2033 I think yeah so
yeah it's I'm
my thoughts on Earth you look at the
policy is fine you're trying to write
you know that what some people view as
an injustice and in the process of
correcting that
Injustice and their quotes
uh you you solve a problem of retaining
people
and recruiting people
and and from a policy committee why
wouldn't you
be unanimous
but when you get down to the
nitty-gritty what it costs and what it
does in terms of unfunded liability it's
a whole different picture
and represent Griffin is a good point
because there are so many priorities
we're looking at trying to retain people
as a three percent ask for those people
providing Home Services only three
percent in
we're looking even in this division we
have any money that we can give division
three to maybe up that a little bit so
four percent five percent but if you put
25 million here you're not going to be
able to help people presently
on that end of this budget scale so yeah
but it's it's 250 million yeah over the
life of the you could do a lot of
retaining with 250 yeah that's true you
could help build a prison yeah well
that's retaining people too you know
so anyway so hopefully we're gonna hear
something by Friday on 436 hopefully we
can make a informed decision
so we're all set with Karen on uh
462 right yeah that was in the budget
yeah yeah ought to pass was seven to one
again it's going to be retained for
hospitals yeah
the next one
next one so then we have 504
Adult Parole Board that was ought to
pass representative Hewitt that was
seven to two
and same thing right that goes in the
budget yeah
so at some time representative Hewitt
you'll have to have a little blurb for
us when we go to the full committee
and that was uh 504
not re
I think that's actually going to be
retained right we're going to put that
in hospital we will still have to talk
to the committee but not necessarily
right
or be ready to speak to it I guess
that's what I should say yeah yes we we
did not have a request to put 504 in the
budget but we can we can get an
amendment for that right I think that's
the way the division is headed
does that make sense Melissa Mr Hoffman
or what should it be standalone
this is an ongoing
yes right you know it is okay
do that
yeah because everybody was getting a
payment I think the chair the vice chair
and wait that was the issue yeah I
remember your comments about that wow
like a 50 pay raise you know
they went with the police there and
again to be Spirit chairman
Commissioners new position but I don't
think you can move as much
because all the other
things
I I think it should be a standalone
pillow why would you well it was
well I thought you were suggesting we
put it in hb2
because it's it's ongoing expenses from
now until
eternity
for for salaries right so why don't we
highlight it I mean you can't in a
budget year you can put all budget bills
in the house bill one or two or you
don't have to a bill could be Standalone
if you want it to be then you could have
a debate on the floor that maybe you
would like to have about the bill or
anybody for that matter but if it goes
in the budget it will be lost in the
budget candid
so the pleasure of the division would
you like it to stand alone
representative Griffin I would all right
okay well then you'll definitely need a
blurb
the committee report
and again I think that's probably a fair
way to do it because it yeah and there's
some disagreement on the division so
keep it alive
all right so we've got that real box
tunnel which again will be coming up
Wednesday that was itl
a to zero represent McGuire
uh the chief security officer
that was a
policy is that going into our hb2
Melissa I don't believe so there's no
fiscal impact on this bill it was just
putting into law so we just had it
passed as is okay but wasn't this just
confirming the position yeah I mean this
could be a bill yeah
so that was you representative Maguire
as you saw that could be consent
couldn't it that could speak in sync I
guess
then we
and relative to assistance for natural
disasters that was
itl
I think that's a committee report from
you representative McGuire
then down to 555 to discuss that already
that was pretty easy
then five
we're still working on that
and then down to 576 administration of
commercial property that was represented
as sweetie working with mangaputi
I think that was
he's already got a blurb for that that's
not on our agenda yet does that not
oh there's no General funds
okay so that can just go on its own I
think
and that is it they're like 26 guys have
done a great job and we really we're in
a good place we have great leadership I
don't know about the leaders
we have a good members I'm very
means with what we've done and
especially with our staff so we're
getting there representative Griffin
I just heard today that the
Senate
uh made
me thinking about putting the
communications tax back in
and replacing and replacing it by
repealing the
utility tax estate the path that goes to
the state
huh
well yeah I mean
should just talk about yeah I mean we
yeah I think representative McGuire has
some good ideas right okay so so here's
what we're thinking about
um
so we have a problem in the house
getting the budget through period right
because normally
at least in my experience it's a hundred
percent partisan the majority votes for
the budget the minority votes against
the budget and you know it passes I mean
that's the way it is
um but there is no majority this year
essentially right and so
um
on any given day it varies and I can
tell you for sure there are some
Republicans even if we are in the
majority on that particular day that
don't like the budget right there's the
you know they're going to vote against
it because it's you know taxation is
theft type of people right so so
um so therefore we gotta have if if
we're going to pass a budget and it
doesn't matter even that you know if
we're going to pass a budget in in April
or we're going to pass a budget in June
you've got to have votes from both sides
and we need to pass a budget so we have
a position at the table yes to
participate with the Senate yeah and and
I think if we do pass a budget in April
we will have super strong bargaining
position with the Senate because we're
going to say look you know just because
we have their votes that day who's gonna
know what votes we have in June 30th
right so you better not change too much
or you better have super good you know
justification for changes because if
they say you know wholesale all kinds of
changes
that may change the whole you know
calculus and dynamics of the whole thing
right so okay
so then yeah go ahead the reason I
brought it up was just so we don't get
blindsided okay so so the question is
what can we do
that
um will attract votes from both sides
right from the holdouts kind of or or
whatever and so maybe there's some
non-budget things that will attract some
votes right and we can talk about that
separately but in terms of money things
and the communication tax
um what I think would it would attract
votes is to change around what tax is
cut okay currently the interest in
dividends tax
is scheduled to Sunset
January 1st 2027.
okay which is
another cycle away
if we change it to January 1st 2025
all right that's
um just before the next legislature
takes if takes office
right so it's within our our fine our
budget right because there's another six
months of our budget to go right at that
moment
and it's essentially two years earlier
right so if we Sunset the interest in
dividends tax two years earlier that
will attract Republican votes because
this is a big deal to to really clean up
not having an interest not having it an
income tax right because this is we're
always on a list of people with income
tax we have an asterisk because we have
this tax right so so that two years
would say it's finally gone you're still
six months away from the next budget
right so it's harder to bring back Etc
okay so that would be very attractive I
think to Republicans
and and to Democrats it says well
compared to current law you're only
um losing two years worth of income from
this tax at the declining rate so you're
talking about a year at two percent and
a year at one percent kind of thing
right or more or less so but to get to
attract Democrat votes what if we don't
get rid of the communication tax
right so the idea is
okay ongoing long term there's another
tax there right because it because the
way the budget is written now there's
two taxes going away right the interest
in dividend taxes going away and the
communication tax is going away but if
we say let's keep the communication tax
to offset the Lost revenue from the
interest and dividends tax then there's
a long-term
um uh Revenue source which presumably
would be attractive
to Democrat votes right so is that just
representative evil so
you know well but I know but you
complained today what about the
communication tax right so yeah so
you see whatever you wish for it do you
see what I mean so so we'd be trading
off sort of a certainty on the interest
and dividends tax going away versus
um a long-term Revenue Source in the
communication tact so
um
that's that's an idea that that we have
to possibly get more votes for the
budget in general okay do do we have any
idea what the IND would be in 26 and 27
I wonder
he's working yeah so
um I think doing what I just described
and and if we don't change the rate of
the interest and dividends tax
in the second year so clearly we're
currently in the interest in dividends X
2023 the rate is four percent
20 calendar year 2023 because it's a
it's a January to December type tax
right so it's currently four percent
right scheduled to be three percent and
two percent like that so if we don't
change the three percent next year
cutting it off six months early is
roughly a 35 million dollar hole okay
but if we leave the communications tax
in it's that's a 56 million dollar thing
right so we're actually gaining money in
this budget
if I if we do what I just described okay
we are hurting the next budget
by roughly I think it's about 40 or so
we can calculate that but but again the
next budget is currently scheduled to
only be in the two percent one percent
group right so
um so it's minimal it's more minimal
anyways and then long term there's an
extra 56 million or whatever the the
communications tax actually is declining
right so it because it's naturally
declined
it is
yeah yes
please bring your name place with you
name plates same plates
think about
are there non-budget things
that would be generally attractive
but I think they're you know there may
be some other discussions to put in
place and I'm not so adversity you know
posting it for people to be able to get
the schedule over Democrats on this
budget okay I don't know what other
direction so we haven't talked to the
other patients about what we've all done
is